geben die geben die leute sich nicht
gleich zu erkennen
unterwegs mit dem kältebus elf mann weiß
und johannes häusern im uns mit durch
frankfurt immer auf der suche nach
menschen in not
[Musik]
auf ihren nächtlichen touren erleben sie
die unterschiedlichsten situationen
[Musik]
los geht es für den kältebus am lager im
ostpark 300 schlafsäcke braucht das team
vom kältebus im jahr aber auch decken
kleidung und natürlich isomatten werden
an obdachlose verteilt und auch
spezielle wünsche werden erfüllt
wir haben auch bauplan für den einen
oder anderen damit damit mir seine
sachen abdecken kann
vollgepackt kann es losgehen
der kältebus fährt eine abgesteckte
route und arbeitet auftrag für auftrag
ab das erste ziel an diesem abend steht
auch schon fest
[Musik]
sie fahren wir mit fan geht aktuell
nicht das lässt die korona pandemie
nicht zu wir fahren hinter her und
bleiben mit den beiden per telefon in
kontakt
ja hallo wir möchten wissen welche
menschen sie nachts vor allem antreffen
an
anderen menschen das sich dann von
eu-weit gelten blitzer zeit
menschen die die
der junge jetzt
gesehen wurden der kältebus ihn gefahren
ist und die sozusagen auch bereit waren
zum beispiel die winter übernachtungen
am eschenheimer tor zu kommen oder die
auch bereit waren mit den ausbau zu
bringen
aber diese teilt nicht psychisch krank
am morgen beim nächsten spielzeit
der erste auftrag an diesem abend ist
ein solcher fall frau psychisch krank
schon lange auf der straße ist auch
nicht zu motivieren in der einrichtung
zu gehen
wir gucken regelmäßig nach ihr
die kann auch sehr aggressiv reagieren
auf uns jetzt nicht weil wir da auch
schon gute beziehung aufgebaut haben mit
der filmen ist da er nichts wir halten
uns zurück und möchten niemanden mit der
kamera belästigen
nicht
mehr zeit als für einen kurzen check
gibt es im moment nicht die auftragslage
ist einfach zu hoch hängt immer von der
wetterlage ab und in so einer extremen
wetterlage dann gehen natürlich die
aufträge nach oben das heißt im
augenblick oder letzten acht irgendwann
mal 75 aufträge und das ist wirklich
schon das ist wirklich schon sehr viel
in normalen nächten sind es um die zehn
aufträge
[Musik]
oft trifft das team vom kältebus vor ort
niemanden an die suche nach bedürftigen
wird dann zum katz und maus spiel
[Musik]
naja die opsec gesehen auch wenn er
diesen
[Musik]
wir haben an besonders eisigen tagen
fährt der kältebus in zwei schichten bis
spät in die nacht
unsere frühschicht neigt sich langsam
dem ende entgegen dass die menschen dem
angebot ganz unterschiedlich begegnen
das gehört dazu
[Musik]
im prinzip ist das eine feine sache dann
kann man sich wenigstens wissen mehrere
die gesellschaft verlassen
gehen sie abends auch in die
notunterkünfte oder sind sie lieber hier
draußen ich bleibe er 1000 euro wollen
wir das nix einbringt
am nächsten tag wieder ein bisschen
vernünftiger denken können für menschen
die beim thema obdachlosigkeit
berührungsängste haben hat erfährt man
weiß noch einen einfachen rat auf die
menschen zugehen man muss ja auch nicht
mit ihnen reden man kann er einfach weg
sagt die 43 als 414 wählen
oder unser beratungs händler anrufen und
dann kommt die sozialarbeiter und nachts
ist erkältet unterwegs und 50 also man
muss jetzt endlich selber machen man
muss es nur mitteilen das ist ganz
wichtig
[Musik]